madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 28 octobre
les premières images des ressortissants
français interpellés au tchad dans le
cadre de la sphère des enfants dits du
darfour
les propos sévères du président idriss
déby et les pourparlers engagés par la
diplomatie française elle assure sa
solidarité avec les enfants étant firmi
légalité de l'opération menée par
l'arche de zoé la grève encore et
toujours air france vols annulés et
retardés des passagers français et
étrangers toujours bloqués aujourd'hui
quatrième jour de conflit et une
question que nous poserons ce soir à
l'un des représentants des stewards et
hôtesses le mouvement va-t-il se
prolonger chaque semaine le sud de la
californie sort d'une semaine d'
incendies après l'accalmie voici l'heure
des craintes écologique et du bilan pour
arnold schwarzeneger nous reviendrons
sur l'omniprésence du gouverneur de
l'état qui a repris pour l'occasion vous
le verrez elle ses habits de héros
d'hollywood
à suivre également dans ce journal du
football avec les résultats de la
journée de ligue 1 est le portrait du
nouvel espoir du football français
il a 19 ans il s'appelle karim benzema
il jouait l'olympique lyonnais mais
intéresse déjà les plus grands clubs
européens
enfin du cinéma avec le dernier gang
signé ariel zeitoun
la mode est au polar enfrance celui ci
est sombre et vif inspiré du fait divers
du gang des postiches
on y retrouve vincent elbaz clémence
poésy et gilles lellouche et et on
commence ce soir par ces images en
provenance du tchad les premières depuis
le début de cette affaire qui dérange à
bien des égards les ressortissants
français membres de l'association
l'arche de zoé sont toujours en garde à
vue et vous allez découvrir le face à
face entre eux eric breteau le président
de l'association qui est à l'origine de
cette opération plus que controversé et
le président tchadien idriss deby qui
lui vous allez le voir quels ici de tous
les maux cette action le commentaire et
de claude son père
voici les premières images des 103
enfants au tchad des images tournées
vendredi par un journaliste local
on y découvre les 81 garçons les vingt
deux petites filles que l'association
l'arche de zoé ou les ramener en france
sur ces images la plupart des enfants
pleurent ils sont apparemment en bonne
santé mais il semble complètement perdu
sur ce document on voit également le
président tchadien en personne idriss
deby qui vient voir les enfants
après quelques photos le président
tchadien va rencontrer les neuf français
de l'association
le leader du groupe eric voto tente
d'expliquer les objectifs humanitaires
de cette opération
regard noir découvert quoi
au 4 octobre
super
on a travaillé
l'année
et les avions vraiment la garantie que
ces enfants et orphelins de père et de
mère est sûre nous a menti c'est
vraiment dans un autre coin du bâtiment
les sept membres d'équipage de l'avion
espagnol
il parle d'un vol humanitaire
le président court
vous irez la peine que vous méritez fin
de l' échange menotté les membres de
l'association les trois journalistes qui
sont avec eux sont en permanence bien
encadrer un peu plus tard devant la
presse le président tient des propos
très durs et porte des accusations sans
preuve
c'est d'enlever les enfants de leurs
parents
le bourg et les enfants de l'autre
et
bande
nous aux associations aux organisations
pédophiles si ce n'est peut-être vendre
qui les pieds battent comme des bêtes
face à cette crise très complexe le quai
d'orsay a mis en place une cellule
d'urgence pour suivre de très près
l'évolution de la situation
voilà des images qui date d'il ya 24
heures et dans cette affaire l'heure est
maintenant à la diplomatie la france
avait très vite condamné cette action
est désormais les déclarations se
succèdent bernard kouchner a pu
s'entretenir avec le président tchadien
est sur place l'ambassade n'a relayé
aujourd'hui encore la position française
qui condamne cette opération des propos
que nous commande sur place notre envoyé
spécial christian hottin aujourd'hui
l'ambassadeur de france au tchad s'est
rendu à bêcher pour visiter l'orphelinat
où ont été recueillies les 103 enfants
il a profité de cette occasion pour
exprimer sa totale condamnation de
l'opération menée par les ong
sheldon rescue je trouve je trouve que
cette situation
nos efforts laissant des prénoms
français a été dû me demander de se
préoccuper en premier lieu du sort de
ces enfants qui ont été arrachés à leurs
villages dans le milieu et ceci n'aurait
jamais dû se produire
il a ensuite qualifié cette opération de
complètement illégale avant d'ajouter
les membres de children rescue qui ont
participé à cette manipulation
répondront de leurs actes au tchad
l'ambassadeur a toutefois ajouté que la
france leur apporterait le concours
consulaires et l'assistance dont ils
auront besoin
on comprend bien ce soir que la sphère
est devenu sur place une affaire d'état
écoutons maintenant les réactions sur
l'évolution de la situation qui est
suivi deux en heure par la diplomatie
française mais également par les membres
de l'association en france pour pour
recueillis par jérôme berlin et daniel
lévy elle épouse d'un membres de l'arche
de zoé détenu à abéché les accusations
du pouvoir tchadien elle les rejette
il n'a jamais était question de trafic
trafic d'enfants au trafic d'organes
tout ceci est n'est pas vrai tout ce que
l'association souhaitait c'était sauver
des enfants au quai d'orsay
rama yade a pris la tête d'une cellule
de crise interrogé sur les accusations
très graves du président deby elle
rappelle que les enquêtes ne sont pas
terminés et fait tout pour ne pas
heurter le pouvoir tchadien quant au
président deby nous sommes parfaitement
solidaire de sa de ces inquiétudes les
choses se passent très bien entre la
france et le tchad
elles continueront à se passait très
bien à la mesure où nous avons décidé de
collaborer très étroitement et les 103
enfants sont toujours recueillis dans
cet orphelinat abéché les autorités
tchadiennes affirme que ce ne sont pas
des réfugiés soudanais mais bel et bien
des tchadiens
le début de l' enquête de l'unicef
semblent leur donner raison je suis
catégorique sur les 48 premiers
entretiens que nous avons pu mener les
48 premiers entretiens
tous ces enfants provenaient de village
tchadienne
le quai d'orsay se dit inquiet des
conséquences de cette affaire pour les
conditions de travail des humanitaires
sur place
voilà ce que nous pouvions dire ce soir
de cette affaire complexe
l'actualité de ce dimanche également
marquée par le conflit à air france un
conflit qui s'enlise
on avait cru lire après 12 heures de
discussions une sortie de crise et puis
les négociations sont finalement revenus
au point mort pas d'évolution
aujourd'hui entre direction et syndicats
avant de retrouver l'un des
représentants des hôtesses et des
stewards voyons quelle était
l'atmosphère aujourd'hui auprès des
passagers
reportage junca chloé cormery il doit
partir à dakar 29 clients d'un tour
operator dans la pagaille de roissy cet
après midi il faut aller chercher des
informations auprès des agents d'air
france
après une demi heure de tentatives
infructueuses
la responsable du groupe jette l'épongé
et décide de distribuer les billets sans
rien savoir
il ya un cadre qu'ils ont
lui de service qui est
que par la vague qui doit sembler as
enseigné j'attends encore qu'il donnait
renseignements en fait il n'en sait pas
plus on a circuit de poilus donc si on
en une journée deux journées on les
rattrapera pas les billets finalement
ils n'ont pas pu s'envoler aujourd'hui
au téléphone le voyagiste parisien qui a
organisé leur séjour vous voulez savoir
un petit peu comment sa situation
évoluer à l'aéroport si vous assure de
partir demain c'est quand même la moins
mauvaise des solutions 1 depuis jeudi ce
tour operator cherche et parfois trouve
des alternatives pour ses 2000 clients
du week end qui devait partir avec air
france c'est très complexe comme
vraiment les vols sont pleins
cependant on arrive a quand même trouvé
des solutions dans ce matin des clients
sont partis en voiture à francfort on
prendre un avion pour bangkok
donc ils ont loué un véhicule pour se
rendre à francfort offre est moyen mais
pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas réussi à
trouver des solutions les vacances
risquent d'être gâchées
ce matin le secrétaire d'état aux
transports dominique bussereau s'est
inquiété de la situation lors d'une
visite à l'aéroport d'orly les vacances
comme ça demain le trafic sera toujours
perturbée 70% des vols air france
seulement devraient être assurés un
conflit qui dure donc depuis quatre
jours maintenant ils touchent à la fois
les aéroports parisiens mais également
ceux de province perturbations à nice ou
encore comme issia à montpellier la
question que tous les passagers se pose
désormais est de savoir jusqu'à quand ce
conflit va durer
le préavis se termine demain à minuit
pour en savoir plus on retrouve
maintenant farid belkacem bonsoir vous
représentez la cgt des personnels
navigants tout d'abord première question
on a vu depuis quatre jours des milliers
de passagers bloqués quelle que soit la
légitimité ou pas de vos revendications
est ce que le choix de ce week-end pour
une grève était vraiment on va dire
opportun écoutez ça fait plus d'un mois
de deux mois en fait que nous avons
déposé ce préavis de grève en fait il y
a eu des réunions successives nous avons
tenté de discuter avec la direction qui
malheureusement n'a jamais écouté nos
propositions et nos revendications
j'aurais quand même dit rappeler
quelques éléments de sur ce conflit il
faut savoir que depuis mille ans 95
les navigants commerciaux d'air france
ont subi plusieurs attaques à commencer
par leurs salaires c'est à dire que du
95 les jeunes embauchés sont rémunérés à
-30%
dans le même temps on nous a imposé 30 %
de productivité de productivité par bond
supplémentaire également dans le même
temps on a également réduit le nombre d
équipage à bord on a densifié le travail
dans les avions
et il faut savoir également que notre
profession accuse le coup maintenant ça
fait maintenant des années qu'on nous
tient à la limite du seuil de rupture
et là ça a vraiment explosé 84%
participation monsieur match était mal
de lui même il faut savoir juste que
j'avais là dessus permettez moi
il faut savoir également que notre
profession et en terme d'accidents du
travail et la deuxième en france après
le docker je crois que c'est un chiffre
qui parle de lui-même
on parle de l'annulation une nouvelle
fois d'un tiers des vols pour demain
vous avez fait une nouvelle proposition
à la direction ou est ce que ce sont
exactement les mêmes que celles d'hier
écoutez nous avons tout à l'heure à 17
heures déposé un protocole de sortie de
conflit à la direction
nous avons toujours sa réponse et nous
espérons qu'elle sera qu'elle sera
positive
sachez bien que nous sommes tous nous
aimerions tous que ce conflit s'achève
dans les meilleures conditions
mais pour autant il faut que la
direction nous écoute maintenant la
balle est dans le camp de la direction
et ce soir nous attendons sa réponse est
ce que cela veut dire que si vous
n'obtenez pas gain de cause le conflit
pourrait durer au delà de votre préavis
qui s'était fixé je crois à demain
minuit
écoutez pour l'instant le conflit
s'achèvera demain
nous avons bon comme je viens de le dire
des réponses de la direction si celle-ci
s'obstine à ne pas répondre à nos
demandes légitimes
nous poursuivrons le mouvement merci de
quelle manière et à quelle date je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas à mener pour
suivre le mouvement
merci farida belkacem et puis notez
cette panne informatique à la sncf les
réservations de billets de train par
internet et sur les bornes automatiques
ont été largement perturbés aujourd'hui
à l'étranger je vous parlais vendredi de
l'accalmie sur le front des incendies en
californie elle s'est confirmée
aujourd'hui mais c'est une autre
question qui inquiète désormais les
autorités elle est d'ordre écologique
ces incendies d'une
intensité rare ont ils rendu l'air
toxiques
la réponse est oui explications florence
mavic ces nuages de fumée toxique mais
les de cendres sont désormais la
préoccupation des californiens les
pompiers savent maîtriser les flammes
mais ils ne peuvent rien contre les
conséquences des incendies sur la santé
des habitants
c'est avec des masses que chacun
s'active dans les ruines des quartiers
dévastés
c'est pas bon et ça ne semble pas
s'arranger
l'odeur est très très présente et c'est
vraiment difficile de respirer à fond
dans l'air flotte de minuscules
particules dangereuses
la fumée vraiment irrespirable les
enfants commencent à tous et moi j'ai
mal à la gorge
les médecins conseillent aux personnes
les plus fragiles de rester chez elle
pour une personne en bonne santé les
conséquences sont pour l'instant minimes
mais pour celles affectées par un
problème pulmonaire ça peut être assez
dangereux en sept jours les incendies
ont émis en gaz à effet de serre
l'équivalent annuel de 440 mille
voitures
le pire est à venir les prochaines
pluies lessive rond les toxines laissés
par les feux et les déverseront dans les
rivières l'eau justement pose aussi
problème
les réservoirs ont été souillés par les
opérations de sauvetage dans plusieurs
communes impossible d'utiliser l'eau du
robinet
de longues files d'attentes se forment
pour se ravitailler en cartons d'eau
minérale pour certains les incendies ont
du bon et cette semaine d'incendié rue
pour conséquence de mettre sur le devant
de la scène le gouverneur de l'état
californien arnold schwarznegger et son
omniprésence a été saluée par tous
soutien des pompiers des sinistrés
monsieur le gouverneur avait apparemment
retenu leçons en matière de
communication du désastre katrina sur
place alain chevron et aaron dimon
dans ces films déjà arnold
schwarzenegger avait le don de se
multiplier seulement c'était du cinéma
et terminator était un méchant rob est
aujourd'hui l'acteur devenu gouverneur
est un gentil plein de compassion qui va
dans les centres d'accueil de réfugiés
s'assurer que tout va bien et comment ça
va c'est bon de vous voir occuper bien
d'elle le gouverneur joue à fond de son
charisme et de son statut de star
mais il est aussi un fin politique qui a
tiré les leçons du désastre de katrina
il ya deux ans la nouvelle orléans sous
les eaux les cafouillages dramatique du
gouvernement
les 1700 morts la chose la plus
importante est de ne pas rester assis
dans son fauteuil et d'essayer de
prendre les bonnes décisions depuis son
bureau il faut être au milieu des gens
c'est essentiel effectivement comme dans
ses films schwarzenegger se multiplient
on le voit partout du petit matin jusque
tard dans la nuit dans les feux dans les
pc de commandement et avec les pompiers
oui surtout avec les pompiers
ils ont la critique facile si on avait
eu plus de moyens aériens on aurait pu
maîtriser ce feu
un petit coup de brosse à reluire et on
en parle plus nous avons sans aucun
doute les meilleurs les plus courageux
plus expérimentés pour pew monde
même ses opposants lui tirent leur
chapeau de ce que j'ai entendu de la
part des citoyens de californie ces
derniers jours
tout le monde apprécie votre leadership
il y a un an il était un peu boiteux
pour sa réélection
aujourd'hui grâce aux incendies il peut
se targuer d'un sans faute et de faire
l'unanimité
déjà au sein du parti républicain on
regrette cet article de la constitution
qui prévoit qu'il faut être né américain
pour devenir président à l'étranger
toujours des images maintenant de
l'armée turque qui s'est à nouveau
déplacé vers sa frontière avec le
kurdistan irakien
près de cent mille hommes ont été
déployés dans la zone une intervention a
d'ailleurs eu lieu aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de séparatistes kurdes
auraient été tués lors d'affrontements
dans l'est de la turquie
les autorités turques ont réaffirmé
qu'elle n'excluait aucune option
militaire comme diplomatique dans ce
dossier ont voté aujourd'hui en
argentine 27 millions d'électeurs
étaient appelés aux urnes pour
l'élection présidentielle
et c'est toujours la sénatrice cristina
kirchner qui apparaît comme la favorite
des sondages
elle et les tenues du président sortant
et a déjà affirmé qu'elle entendait
poursuivre la politique de son mari
on ne connaîtra les résultats que tard
dans la soirée
en espagne la polémique enfle après la
béatification par le vatican de près de
500 religieux qualifié de mort en martyr
durant la guerre civile espagnole
une béatification que certains juge
inopportune et qui embarrasse le
gouvernement espagnol
voyons pourquoi avec franck gensous
sur la place saint pierre ils sont
plusieurs milliers à être venus assister
à la béatification de 498 personnes des
prêtres et des religieuses espagnoles
assassinés pendant la guerre cible c'est
la plus grande messe de béatification
jamais organisé au vatican
les pèlerins sont tous venus d'espagne
ce sont des martyrs car ils ont été
victimes de persécutions religieuses
beaucoup de gens sont morts c'est la
reconnaissance d'une gaffe à l'épaule à
la religion ces gens sont morts pour
dieu et pour les sondages l'espagne une
cérémonie à l'origine d'une polémique en
espagne au moment où le pays s'apprête à
voter une grande loi pour reconnaître
d'autres victimes
celle de la dictature france durant la
guerre civile
les républicains avaient tué un grand
nombre de religieux mais certains
religieux ont également participé à la
chasse aux républicains aux côtés des
troupes de franco pour les familles de
victimes
l'église espagnole oublié aujourd'hui
cette facette de l'histoire
ils ne reconnaissent que le rôle de
victime alors qu'on faisait aussi partie
des bourreaux ils ont participé aux
assassinats ils ont fait des listes de
personnes tuées par la suite et pendant
40 ans l'église a été un des piliers la
dictature de franco
une polémique qui met aujourd'hui dans
l'embarras causé 8 zapatero le premier
ministre espagnol a été obligé de
dépêcher un émissaire à la cérémonie
à quelques jours des premières
discussions sur la loi le vatican de son
côté réfute toute volonté de mettre face
à face les deux événements en france ce
drame aujourd'hui dans l'aude assiégeant
un homme et une femme âgés d'une
cinquantaine d'années ont trouvé la mort
ce matin après avoir été fauché par une
voiture alors qu'il se promenait le
conducteur avait tout d'abord fui mais
si c'est ensuite vous allez le voir
rendu à la gendarmerie reportage
léo lamberton dit spica totalement
dépassés par ce qu'il vient de commettre
le conducteur du véhicule seront aux
gendarmes il a passé deux heures cachées
non loin du lieu de l'accident et le
jeune homme âgé d'une vingtaine d'années
visiblement sous le choc
ce matin à 9h30 sur cette route
départementale près d'ostie gens dans
l'aude au volant de son pick-up
il heurte un couple d'une cinquantaine
d'années qui se promènent sur le bas
côté
l'homme et la femme sont tués le
conducteur abandonne son véhicule et
s'enfuit un vaste dispositif de
recherche est alors lancé nous sommes à
la recherche de ce conducteur nous avons
déployé un important dispositif avec des
moyens aériens l'hélicoptère de
montpellier un maître chien est à peu
près une trentaine de personnels qui
sont déployées sur la zone et qu'il
recherche
placé en garde à vue le jeune homme a
expliqué qu'il avait passé la nuit à
faire la fête et qui s'est endormi au
volant
le test d'alcoolémie s'est révélé
positif quant aux résultats des analyses
toxicologiques
elles seront connus demain et puis hier
soir cet autre délit de fuite en moselle
cette fois à les deux adolescentes ont
été renversés par un conducteur qui ne
s'est pas arrêté le pronostic vital de
l'une des jeunes filles est engagée jeu
phare âgé de 54 ans a pu être interpellé
ce matin à paris aujourd'hui un
rassemblement était organisé à
l'initiative de nadine trintignant
rassemblement pour protester contre les
violences faites aux femmes plus de 400
personnes étaient présentes et parmi
elles de nombreuses personnalités du
monde du spectacle
pierre monnet gier marie cros de sa
colère elle a fait un combat
nadine trintignant a rassemblé autour
d'elle des écrivains des réalisateurs
des comédiens pour dénoncer les
violences faites aux femmes
elle n'a pas voulu s'exprimer sur la
remise en liberté de bertrand cantat qui
a tué sa fille en 2003 mais exige des
peines plus lourdes à l'encontre des
hommes violents
un crime c'est un crime nazi un crime un
crime qui touche chaque jour des
centaines de femmes marie trintignant
n'était que l'une d'entre elles mais cet
après midi son souvenir et c'est dans
tous les esprits quand vous entendez des
horreurs et les nombres c'est évidemment
à supporter indéfiniment
ni par marie trintignant est morte à
samedi soir comme pratiquement tous les
week-ends en france ça arrive à une
femme c'est évidemment interpellant
quand j'entends dire des choses aussi
terrible j'ai vraiment honte d'être un
homme comme on peut quand on peut avoir
honte au premier degré simplement c'est
pas une honte intellectuelle c'est une
honte physique que des hommes se
comportent comme ça en récession tout le
monde du spectacle
les associations de défense des femmes
battues espère jeter un coup de
projecteur sur une réalité tragique en
france tous les trois jours une femme
meurt victime de violences conjugales
économie le gouvernement examinera
mercredi un projet de loi sur plusieurs
questions concernant les consommateurs
des questions parfois concrète de votre
quotidien
la fin des tarifs téléphoniques surtaxés
pour les hotlines ou encore l'obligation
pour les banques de présenter à un
récapitulatif annuel de leurs frais
explication caroline thébaux charles
baget
dans cette hotline ni le temps
d'attentes ni la communication ne sont
facturés aux clients une exception qui
pourrait bientôt devenir la règle
aujourd'hui la plupart des fournisseurs
d'accès internet sur facture ses
services d'assistance pour free neuf
cegetel août et les deux comptait 34
centimes d'euros par minute échanger
avec le conseiller
une surfacturation que le projet de loi
compte interdire autres secteurs
concernés les banques elles devraient
envoyer à leurs clients une fois par an
un récapitulatif de leurs frais
bancaires frais parfois insoupçonnées
comme la réédition d'un code secret si
vous avez oublié le vôtre ça va
permettre plus de transparence de
manière à ce que le consommateur puisse
éventuellement discuter avec son
banquier
et puis le cas échéant aller voir la
concurrence côté téléphonie mobile le
gouvernement reste flou sur ses petites
lignes là tout en bas celle qui concerne
les durées d'engagement quand vous
achetez un portable réduire de 24 à
douze mois les contrats
c'est ce que demandent toujours les
associations de consommateurs tant que
le consommateur ne sera pas libre sera
captifs sera entraînée vers d engagement
de 24 mois
eh bien le marché ne sera pas dynamique
donc il faut une intervention
législative le temps de la concertation
et terminer l'année dernière 30 mille
plaintes ont été déposées dans le
secteur des communications souvent pour
des problèmes de résiliation de contrat
le temps de la réforme des institutions
est il venu nicolas sarkozy s'y était
engagé pendant la campagne électorale et
bien c'est demain matin que l'ancien
premier ministre edouard balladur lui
remettra son rapport sur ce thème au
programme 70 cette proposition les
grandes lignes avec ellen hughes et
d'années de lévis ni révolution ni
changement de régime mais la copie
rendue par le comité balladur propose
une cinquième république plus
démocratique
la prééminence du président de la
république est consacré c'est lui et non
plus le gouvernement qui définirait la
politique de la nation
le droit de prendre la parole devant le
parlement lui serait accordé son
allocution pourrait être suivie d'un
débat
mais en aucun cas d'un vote une mesure
diversement appréciée un président
enfants
pleinement responsable et un exécutif
enfin pleinement responsable qui rendent
compte de leurs actes devant un
parlement
devenu adulte l'assemblée nationale n'a
aucun pouvoir sur le pays dans la
république est la nuit droit de réponse
neil pouvoir de sang tellement chaud que
dans la république pour renforcer le
parlement d'abord lui donner la maîtrise
de la moitié de son ordre du jour
augmenter le nombre de commissions
parlementaires 10 au lieu de six
actuellement lui demander son avis sur
la nomination des hauts fonctionnaires
enfin limiter l'usagé du 49-3 qui
permettent au gouvernement de faire
adopter un texte sans vote pour
renforcer la démocratie 20 à 30 députés
pourraient être élus à la
proportionnelle
proposition rejetée aussi bien par les
petits que par les grands partis
il est normal que tous les grands
courants politiques du pays soient
représentés convenablement à l'assemblée
est un vrai honneur des députés de dire
votre mandat on le doit aux citoyens
davantage qu'au parti avec la
proportionnelle vous casser sa
référendum d'initiative populaire ou
interdiction du cumul des mandats
suscite aussi la polémique
faute de consensus l'elysée à d'ores et
déjà renvoyé la révision
constitutionnelle après les municipales
de 2008
parlons environnement avec cette
nouveauté pour les plus petits avec des
crèches écolo du sol au plafond en
passant par l'alimentation des enfants
tout est bio l'une des premières crèches
du genre a été ouverte
à côté de ville reportage à la madeleine
l à palo patrick bullestorm la petite
collation du matin
un grand classique dans les crèches mais
je suis tout est bio du biscuit au jus
de carotte et ça ne s'arrête pas là
cette crèche d'entreprise a voulu faire
100% écolo en commençant bien sûr par
les couches
ici on utilise des changes lavables en
bambou et coton bio et tant pis si ces
quelques peu volumineux c'est plus
écologique
on accueille de 30 enfants ont fait 3 4
change par jour donc ce qui fait qu'on a
besoin de vie comme de deschamps - font
la nique au sol à base de lin
peintures murales en argile et hanches
au bois non traité tous les produits
potentiellement toxiques sont éliminés
même les matelas et les turbulette sont
en coton bio les parents semblent
conquis par le concept
j'ai plutôt rassurante on par an on a
l'impression de faire quelque chose
d'utile en plus on sait que nos enfants
sont bien issues sont heureux pour
l'avenir le fait que les enfants soient
déjà dans un environnement développement
durable c'est déjà les sensibiliser et
les entreprises elles aussi sont
séduites
les concepteurs de cette crèche bio vont
ouvrir des nouvelles structures l'année
prochaine et ils vont encore plus loin
dans la protection de l'environnement
cette future crèche et d'avant-garde pas
de fondations une structure envoie des
murs remplis de paille bio provenant de
la région du triple vitrage
il ne faudra même pas chauffée en hiver
c'est un bâtiment qui qui démontre que
on peut simplement à un coût de
construction est tout à fait normal
construit un bâtiment extrêmement
performant qui consomme plus d'énergie
pour fonctionner et pour aller encore
plus loin
il envisage même de récupérer ce que les
petits pensionnaires des crèches laisse
au fond de leur couche pour le
transformer en énergie sport avec du
football et deux matches de ligue 1
rennes s'est imposé en fin de journée à
l'extérieur sur la pelouse du racing
club de lens 2 buts à 1 buts de sylvain
ville tordent et celui maintenant de
jérôme leroy rennes occupe désormais la
troisième place
pendant ce temps là le mans a fait match
nul avec toulouse 1 but partout
et ce soir le paris saint germain reçoit
le leader l'olympique lyonnais lyon qui
a vu éclore depuis le début de la saison
un talent durant d'espoir karim benzema
est passé à celui de star du football
français s'est imposé en équipe de
france et en championnat comme un joueur
et un buteur incontournable
un parcours qui suscite déjà les
convoitises des plus grands clubs
européens
portrait signé florent gautreau et vassy
la camry une perle rare à lyon karim
benzema 19 ans est ici chez lui il est
né sur les bords du rhône et depuis
l'âge de 9 ans il fait les beaux jours
de l'olympique lyonnais avec les jeunes
comme avec les professionnels benzema
impressionne tous ses entraîneurs par
son aisance technique et son efficacité
devant le but
quand cet été son club a cherché à
recruter un attaquant il a pris la
parole revendiquant une place de
titulaire au milieu des stars lyonnaises
c'est que j'ai confiance en moi et je
connais mes qualités j'ai pas parlé pour
rien donc voilà si j'ai dit ça c'est que
je me sentais le dirait aujourd'hui ça
se passe bien et j'espère que je vais
continuer à travailler
il restait comme suit 10 à l'heure où
les vedettes du foot hexagonal s'exiler
à l'étranger le public français peut se
réjouir d'admirer chaque semaine un
joueur exceptionnel qui a déjà marqué 11
buts en 11 matches de championnat
benzema a déjà tapé dans l'oeil des plus
grands selon le journal espagnol marca
le jeune attaquant de l'ol aurait séduit
les recruteurs du real madrid le real
comme zidane auquel on le compare déjà
il faut dire que benzema a pris la bonne
habitude de se mettre dans les pas de
l'ex idole de la france du foot
zidane avait marqué pour sa première
sélection avec les bleus en 94 et bien
benzema limite 13 ans plus tard après
seulement huit minutes passées sous le
maillot bleu l'attaquant lyonnais marque
mais l'idole de benzema ce n'est pas
zidane c ronaldo ses passements de
jambes son palmarès et son adresse
incroyable
bon je peux regarder des vidéos lui
moi j'aime bien ce qui fait ce qu'il
veut j'en prends toujours or dans les
grands jours le real madrid le piste
thierry henry voit en lui son successeur
il a déjà marqué trois buts en six
sélections avec les bleus mais benzema
ne s'enflamme pas il vit chez ses
parents s'est acheté une maison avec ses
premiers salaires et a prolongé son
contrat avec lyon
la nouvelle star du foot français a des
pieds en or mais la tête sur les épaules
quand le cinéma s'inspire d'un sombre
fait divers celui du gang des postiches
avec la sortie mercredi du dernier gang
un film signé ariel zeitoun et c'est
vincent elbaz qui incarne le cerveau de
la bande parce qu'elle deschamps et
frédéric capron reviennent sur cette
affaire la police a quelques bonnes
heures cette semaine puisque vient
d'arrêter mais à paris cette fois trois
gangsters appartenant à la gang des
postiches
musquin gang et c'était devenu une
légende pendant six ans ils ont nargué
la police des dizaines de cas ce en
plein jeu brille mais d'où leur surnom
des centaines de millions de francs d'or
de bijoux soustrait des coffres des
particuliers dès 1980 avec l'arrivée de
mitterrand et des communistes ils vont
planquer tous leurs polluantes ou le
black les lingots les bijoux ils vont
les mettre dans des coffres eux il était
populaire et c'est ça qui était un peu
troublant pourquoi c'est parce qu'en
fait ils agissaient et il faisait croire
peut-être qu'ils agissaient comme des
robins des bois et il donnait
l'impression d'aller venger les les gens
qui avaient pas les moyens d'inquiéter
en crise d'aller prendre aux riches
les vols en vain c'est quoi un scanner à
chapais toutes les fréquences de la
police
orange est dans tout et de ressorts du
coin c'est pas beau ça il avait des
moyens à l'époque nous n'avions pas à
savoir des scanners qui permettait post
radio qui permettait d'entendre les
services de police et les les fréquences
police alors que nous n'avions pas
encore l'époque de postes cryptée va
quand on est une bande de potes comme
une indigence une bande qui né dans les
faubourgs de belleville de petites
phrases devenues dépôt des années de
braquages et de planck que le film suit
pas à pas on ne saura jamais vraiment
qu'ils étaient seuls trois d'entre eux
seront arrêtés parmi eux une énigme
andré bellaïche cerveau supposé du gang
dont la culpabilité n'a jamais été
prouvée il a fait huit ans de prison
pour association de malfaiteurs il a
aujourd'hui 57 ans faut savoir que le
bond du titre on ne sait pas un jeu tel
que ça finit toujours mal de toute
manière et même quand ça finit bien ça
finit mal de toute manière
je ne voudrais pas vraiment que quelques
jeunes de banlieue comme ça pense que je
fuis de prendre une arme et de de tuer
quelqu'un de très grosses conneries pour
être un quelqu'un de valeureux je pense
que quelqu'un de malheureux je suis
quelqu'un qui construisent mais tel est
le sentiment qui étreint spectateurs à
la sortie derrière le spectaculaire le
flamboyant il ya des destins brisés deux
fils de voyous victime laissés sur le
carreau et une question pour les
survivants pourquoi
on reste dans l'image avec la fin du
festival d'antibes est un festival dédié
au monde sous marin
plusieurs films ont été projetés durant
cinq jours on y retrouve souvent des
images magnifiques mais également
certaines plus étonnant la sélection est
signée jérôme berlin et virgile gâteau
si vous venez de finir de dîner gare à
l'indigestion car voici le grand festin
52 minutes de carnage
le calvaire des sardines en pleine
migration sud de l'afrique
les bancs de poissons peuvent atteindre
20 km de long 3 km de large des sardines
par milliards un buffet à volonté
requins dauphins fous de bassan et au
bout de la chaîne les hommes il n'y a
pas que les pêcheurs sur les plages tout
le monde vient se servir c'est gratuit
on ne sait plus où mettre les sardines
dans ses bras dans son t-shirt et même
dans ses chaussures
les gens deviennent tout fait ce temps
c'est connu se termine en chanson voici
le premier câble sous marin
ce clip est l'oeuvre d'un seul homme
graphisme musique même le rappeur et
bien c'est lui le père du nourrisson
c'est vrai que c'est plus tellement de
mon âge c'est vrai que cette envie
réaction des enfants puisque ça parle un
petit peu de professions la protection
du mont du monde marin des choses comme
ça la protection des fonds marins
même la pub s'en empare
et si la mère décidé de nous renvoyer
tous que nous y avons déversé à travers
l'histoire c'est la rébellion du
dépotoir
c'est aussi une publicité pour une vodka
représenté comme la quintessence de la
pureté
c'est ce qu'on appelle du recyclage ou
de la récupération avant de terminer ce
journal je vous rappelle un des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
dimanche la grève qui se poursuit air
france
les négociations sont toujours bloqués
et des divisions apparaissent au sein
des syndicats puisque la cgt a proposé
unilatéralement un protocole d'accord ce
soir on s'oriente vers un cinquième jour
de grève pour la journée de demain
voilà pour l'actualité de ce dimanche
merci de nous être fidèles dans un
instant la météo nathalie rihouet 20h50
harry potter et le prisonnier d'azkaban
troisième volet inédit de la saga pour
trouverez dès demain pour l'information
et les u6 à 13h et françoise laborde à
20h passé une très belle soirée
m
et maintenant
merci